six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number let's see who else here we're
gonna go to a call from Skype and those
are always I mean you know what happens
Pat it can be very good or very very bad
I mean someone's just like someone
calling International Haven it miles
again from Arizona
go ahead miles what's going on
background are you at a firing range or
where where are you know I'm on the
school lunch field okay sorry about that
let me I'm just trying to find a lighter
spot another problem what's your
question today mile what so one second
hang on I'm kind of remember what does
uh it was I kind of I remembered the
question and I completely forgot it
write it down um oh so John Bolton was
found to have led this anti-muslim
almost group that was working with
Russian bots you see John Bolton the
current National Security Advisor
potentially become entangled in molars
investigation I don't see yeah I know
what you're talking about I don't see
him as becoming entangled in molars
investigation because he just joined the
Trump administration and you would need
some path for Moeller and I don't know
that just the fact that molar games
online that Bolton's accused of this
stuff would make him part of the
investigation he was he's not really
part of the chain that got Trump either
elected so I I am I am aware of the
reports they're very disturbing reports
but I don't see it becoming part of
Muller's investigation and so kind of
expanding on the question I asked last
time how much if you had to put it into
a percentage do you think the
information about the molar
investigation has been made public or
how much do you think we know I would
7.2 percent I think we know somewhere
between 7.2 and 7.4 percent of what
Muller knows really like that
that little baby seven-point-eight
understand you know I know if they look
at that are flowing yeah a one final
question do you think some of the
information molar is holding or keeping
classified could be more indictments
like I'm just wondering why haven't we
seen more people indicted yet like
Kushner Don Jr don't like that I think
the answer is absolutely I think there
are pending indictments that Muller is
holding because he is either negotiating
with some of those future indict EES to
see what they are willing to do flip
talk about but yes certainly I think
that there are already people that
Moeller knows will be getting indicted
that we don't yet know about all right
that's all David that's all David thank
thanks for taking my call again
all right then miles by the way were we
on speakerphone the entire call um no I
was using my computer again using
headphones very good all right thanks
miles thank you so much really
appreciate it and all right miles miles
checking in there I wonder if there are
things that we know that molar does not
yeah